you all know I call things as I see them
and right now it's time to call the
virus situation as I see it idiots and
bad people are destroying our ability to
curb this virus as soon as possible
their behavior is putting people at risk
and it will cause people to die
unnecessarily people who didn't need to
die now I'm not just talking about the
people in our government I'm also
talking about just regular old people
you might remember old I just mean
regular people not elderly I did a story
back in February of last year about 13
months ago called it's time to admit
that many Americans are stupid and
clearly this struck a nerve it got more
than 600,000 views a very positive
reaction
more than 16,000 likes but a lot of
people didn't like it a lot of people
felt that it was an attack on them to
some degree or on on people who just
lacked education and this is not what we
are talking about we have never had a
clearer case of bad and dumb people will
be the death of us then what is
happening now in the era of coronavirus
coronavirus has exposed the deficits in
our systems the deficits in our health
care system in our economy in our
presidents capacity to deal with a
crisis a total lack of capacity that is
but we're also hurting because of bad
and dumb people and I'm going to go
through some examples with you today
of course the context being to stop the
spread of the virus
absent functioning antivirals a vaccine
antibody treatments all of which are
under development it's gonna be a while
we need to reduce exposure and
transmission stop gathering in large
groups work from home stay away from
other people all this stuff many states
are realizing it's shutting down bars
and restaurants and gatherings even as
large as 25 people look at just a
sampling of what happened over the
weekend this is just a handful of
examples there are hundreds or thousands
of these Oklahoma Republican Governor
Kevin stit posted a tweet of himself out
with his kids in a very crowded
restaurant sing eating with my kids and
all my fellow Oklahomans at the
collective OKC
it's
pack tonight this is the exact opposite
of what medical experts say we should do
and of course we live in a world where
one party has decided medical experts
are basically just people with opinions
which we can ignore if we don't like
them because it's just like saying I
think low taxes are good it's just an
opinion
our Republican governor here in
Massachusetts is taking the seriously
activating a system to get nurses from
out of state licensed in-state within 24
hours to keep up with demand saying
close schools work from home starting a
restaurant and bar closure other than
takeout and delivery starting tomorrow
and meanwhile the Oklahoma governor is
bragging about being at a packed
restaurant with his kids
is this weaponized ignorant or is this a
bad person you tell me governor
eventually deleted the tweet because of
the obvious blowback people are hoarding
people are hoarding food of all kinds
people are hoarding toilet paper this is
creating an artificial shortage there
was no expectation that the supply chain
was actually going to be disrupted for
toilet paper nor that toilet paper usage
would actually go up but people are
going crazy and they're doing it with
food as well
here's video of people rolling around on
the ground pushing each other yelling at
each other and fighting for toilet paper
at some big box store I don't even know
where this is doesn't matter it's
happening all over for toilet paper
[Music]
again this is all started by rumor about
a shortage people go fight for toilet
paper and they cause a shortage because
people are hoarding it if people just
kept buying toilet paper at their normal
rate using it at their normal rate
there'd be no shortage there'd be no
scuffles for people pushing each other
in order to get grab toilet paper are
these stupid people or are they bad
people I don't know the answer more and
more in blue states people are staying
home st. Patrick's Day Parade here in
Boston cancelled if you're from the area
you know just how big of a deal that is
not everywhere though here's a girl at
some kind of Saint Patrick's Day street
party talking about well I'm 21 I'm
immunocompromised but I don't care
because I take supplements I'm not even
worried because I just take supplements
and like I self-medicate so it's fine is
this a dumb person or is this a bad
person for lack of a better term South
Korea has tested large numbers of
asymptomatic 22 29 year-olds and found
that a whole bunch of 22 29 year-olds
who feel fine have the virus
and they are spreading it all over if
they do what this girl is doing it has
to stop here is Republican congressman
Devin Nunez going on Trump brown-noser
Maria Bartiromo is program on Fox and
saying hey you know what this is a great
time to go out to a restaurant it's not
that busy you can get right in and get a
table and there's a lot of concerns with
the economy here because people are
scared to go out but I will just say one
of the things you can do if you're
healthy you and your family it's a great
time to just go out go to a local
restaurant yeah likely you can get in
get in easily there's you know let's not
hurt the working people in this country
that are relying on wages and tips
keep their small business very
sympathetic run to the don't run to the
understated I just don't run to the
grocery store and buy buy you know four
thousand dollars of food I don't you
know go to your local local pub very
sympathetic to what's going on no
pushback from Maria Bartiromo should
that be criminal what Devon Nunez said I
tweeted asking should this be criminal a
whole bunch of my Twitter follower said
yeah what Devon Nunez is doing there
should be criminal and now Devon Nunez
isn't wrong to be concerned about the
economy the economy is in a freefall but
the problem is a systemic structural one
the solution isn't to now say well we
have to just keep going to bars and
restaurants what we need is a system of
paid sick leave so he can be less
concerned about the restaurant employees
not having disbanded the pandemic
response team having a functioning
health care system these are structural
problems that they don't get solved by
saying go at the individual level and
continue to engage in the behavior
that's spreading the disease if we are
going to have this level of both
stupidity and just straight-up disregard
for others we are in very very serious
trouble and as we see the partisan
divide Republicans have to a third as
likely to be worried about coronaviruses
Democrats to be taking action around
coronaviruses Democrats we are in a
situation that is only going to get
worse that's where the data is pointing
right now if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blink its blink Isleta consume an entire
book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
non-fiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinky blink East has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different nonfiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month and you get
the entire library but you can try it
totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video